[Music]
if evolution plays a role in
consciousness does this mean that
consciousness provides a survival
benefit and could the same behaviors be
selected without consciousness uh don
you see consciousness as being a
mechanism which can determine fitness
payoffs right
well
actually not so so i think that from the
point of view that i've been talking
about space time isn't fundamental so
and i propose instead that consciousness
is fundamental and we can have a
mathematical model of consciousness that
um is is so called stationary but when
we project that model
we will get
time emerging as a projection an
artifact and so we will get to something
that looks like evolution so so in other
words
when we say that space time is doomed
when the physicists say this like neymar
connie met ed whitton nathan cyberg and
and and and several others
are saying that space time was doomed is
not fundamental
to be clear i'm not sure they say it the
way you're saying it but
go ahead
well
if i mean like like
so so
the point is that evolution is a
consequence or a driver
so yeah i would say that evolution
is a consequence of a deeper
reality that's outside of space and time
so
what what we have from an evolutionary
point of view is not a window on the
truth when i see the sun and the moon
and the earth i'm not seeing a window on
reality i'm just seeing a virtual
reality headset
that i've that evolution has given me to
survive long enough to reproduce and
that headset in any headset will will
simplify certain things
and and basically eliminate other
information so
for example the distinction that we make
between living and non-living we think
of that as a principal distinction it's
merely an artifact of the limitations of
our particular evolved headset
and so so that that's not a fundamental
distinction are you cascading into
skepticism
uh absolutely not so so i think that
what i'm doing i'm just saying we have
to take our current best scientific
theories very seriously it's a theorem
of both of both evolution financial
selection and quantum field theory with
gravity that space-time does not make
sense as fundamental reality that's just
a theorem of our best of our best
current science and so as a scientist i
have to take our current theories very
seriously they don't tell us what's
outside of space-time all they tell us
is that for example the physicists know
that beyond 10-33 centimeters
space-time has no operational meaning
there is nothing that you can make
operational about and 10 to the minus 43
seconds and what they're finding are
these deep structures beyond space-time
that have symmetries that like the
amplitude heatran it has symmetries that
are true of the data of scattering
and cannot be seen in space-time even if
i give you all of that which i don't but
if i give you all of that
what well what is the what is the
relationship between consciousness and
evolution i'm still trying to determine
which which drives the other in
in your world view
well so in my world view consciousness
would be fundamental and there's a
dynamics of consciousness that need not
be a that has no entropic time
but when you take the the model i'm
working on with my team is that when we
take this this dynamics of consciousness
that has no entropic time the the
entropy is constant
but when you take any projection of it
then you get as an artifact of the
projection the illusion of well you get
an increasing entropy in that projection
of the dynamics and so
what what i'm looking for is that not
only is space-time emergent as a
projection of a deep model of
consciousness but that the notion of
entropic time itself emerges and
therefore evolution by natural selection
all of it will come out as a projection
of a deeper theory in which perhaps
there is no competition and no limited
resources the limiting resource idea
limited time is an artifact of a
projection onto a particular point of
view is not fundamental
you don't have evolution being
deterministic though right right if
evolution is derivative of this
something else it's not it's not an
illusion that we see it the way
biologists have
you're not claiming that
you know it'll it'll be a probabilistic
theory and it will probably
well what we have to do is show that a
deeper theory of the evolution of
consciousness that is non-temporal in
the sense that there's no entropic time
leads to entropic time leads to all of
the evolution of natural selection that
we know and love inside of space and
time as a special case a projection of a
much deeper theory in which space and
time simply are not interesting
predicates okay no it's much deeper than
that no one will will accuse you of uh
of uh of
blandly supporting the status quo of
thinking
go big or go home
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv